the mountains are where I for sure feel
the most like myself
[Music]
they don't care who you are or what you
do and I think that they kind of have
taught me so much about awareness really
in consciousness
[Music]
being a big mountain skier is a
dangerous sport and I've lost so many
friends that I can't count them on two
hands and that's kind of this thing that
you have to accept with being in the
mountains that you're gonna face it and
it's not going to stop and I've asked
myself when I lose close people to my
life
why do you really do this what is it
about it but this is a passion and how
do you take that away from someone I
don't think you really can
[Music]
you know for me my dad was athletic
growing up so therefore that was like
something that he knew to teach me you
really didn't see that boundary and so I
grew up not really feeling like there
was a boundary
I started professionally skiing when I
was 16 years old pretty early on it was
very apparent that the women were far
outnumbered so I'm 30 now and it's taken
me that long to feel comfortable in my
skin with my skillset to be like I can
go on this trip with these guys who are
role models of mine and feel like I'm
one of them or feel like I'm on par with
them I'm so thankful for them for their
mentorship it's a totally different vibe
when you go out with the mountains with
women women and men work differently and
we work differently when we're in the
mountains that sense of community or
like support was really strong and we
could push each other like if you see
another female do something you're like
oh I can do that
say fast clinics was conceptualized
after a couple of my closest friends got
caught and survived this huge Avalanche
being we started talking about how we
felt like being a female in the
mountains is different than being a male
in the mountains and maybe we should
start like an all-women's a vilage
clinic I think it's super important to
be an amount of other women and I think
all sometimes we're normally outnumbered
right when you start learning about
avalanche awareness it's like oh this is
real and this could happen to me and so
I think it's really important to inspire
them with confidence hopefully you guys
will walk away knowing how cool and be
much more comfortable traveling the
backcountry you know I didn't go to
college I chose the route of being a
professional skier and to be honest when
I was younger I thought that that was a
really selfish job
and it wasn't until a few years later
when I kind of grew up and kind of
realized that maybe maybe one day I
could have a big enough name that I
could do positive things with my name
and spread that love and spread that
life
[Music]
so yeah I'm with professionals here I'm
a big mountain skier if you want to get
specific but I don't really see my
entire job or my entire livelihood based
on just skiing I think it's really
important for young women to have strong
female role models when someone tells me
that I'm an inspiration that touches me
so deeply
[Music]
[Music]
what I do is I chase the winter and I
chase good snow but there's a lot more
to it
[Music]
[Music]